again like the point i was trying to
make that the the 1.8 million votes you
got the 1.2 percent the count the states
that you got it you know uh georgia 14
152 votes in georgia you had 61 000 792
in that state that's 16 electoral that
would have gone the other way arizona
had forty nine thousand one eighty two
wisconsin he had thirty eight thousand
four fifteen that's ten electoral
electoral votes that would ended up
being a tie 269 269 if you can john if
you can show that on the screen and zoom
it in a little bit more so people can
see it so just to kind of give some
context here as well the the 14 000
votes is what biden beat trump with in
that state and then obviously you have
the gap which is you in the middle there
uh on those votes as well so just with
these four states you you could make i
mean i know that people do make the
argument zoom in a little bit people
those would have pushed you over would
have pushed one way or the other uh and
then possibly pushed for for trump on
that end as well yeah well as i said
many people from the left also vote
libertarian and in the past historically
it's about 50 50 although most of our
votes
come from independents or people who
have never voted before so if somebody's
never voted before and and many people
came up to me when i was on the campaign
trail saying
it wasn't worth it for me to vote for
before i'm 30 years old 40 years old
whatever because everybody out there is
just the typical politicians but typical
politician but you're different and so
i don't think they would have voted for
trump if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]